clear them out while show in the latest
evidence that we are shifting the
Overton window the New York Times is now
acknowledging the dangers of puberty
blockers also with the help of several
Republicans Democrats in the Senate now
have a filibuster-proof majority to
redefine marriage at the federal level
plus a prominent physicist claims that
there are more than two human Sexes The
View Frets about Republicans raising the
voting age to 28 I wish and the U.S
men's soccer team replaces the American
flag with the pride flag all of that and
more today on the Matt Walsh show
foreign
[Music]
you know inflation continues to plague
our economy the daily wire reports that
in less than two years inflation has
soared from 1.4 percent to 8.6 percent
as of May 2022 the price of gasoline was
up nearly 49 the price of meat poultry
and fish was up 14.2 percent and the
price of used cars was up 16 the current
Administration is irresponsible spending
patterns including Biden's 1.9 trillion
dollar rescue plan continue to
exacerbate the problem now you know this
is not the time to have all of your
money tied up in the stock market don't
let your savings wither away hedge
against inflation with gold from Birch
gold text Walsh to 989898 and Birch gold
will send you a free info kit on
protecting your savings with gold Birch
gold is giving out a free gold bar with
any Purchase made by December 22nd but
you have to submit your claim to get
this offer by Black Friday with almost
20 years of experiencing and converting
IRAs and 401ks into precious metal IRAs
Birch gold can help you do the same
don't sit around while the fed devalues
your hard-earned money text Walsh to
98989 okay and learn how you can convert
at least part of your savings into a
precious metals Ira if you place an
order by December 22nd Birch gold will
send you a free gold bar so text Walsh
to 989898
well it's only Tuesday but the New York
Times has already had an interesting
week it began on Sunday with an article
about age restrictions for tattoos the
piece begins with this anecdote it says
last month a ten-year-old boy walked
into the nurse's office of his
Elementary School in Highland New York
and asked for some Vaseline he wanted to
rub it onto his new tattoo a crude
rendering of his name in large block
letters on the inside of his forearm the
nurse called the police the boy had
gotten the tattoo with his mother's
permission from a neighbor according to
local authorities while some states have
no minimum age for receiving a tattoo if
a parent allows it New York State
forbids anyone younger than 18 from
getting tattooed with or without
parental consent last month both the
tattoo artist Austin Smith 20 who was
unlicensed and the boy's mother Crystal
Thomas 33 were arrested as picture of
the pictures of the boy's arms stirred
outrage across local and international
news sites and social media
well we're then told that tattoos are
becoming more and more common and
socially acceptable which is not exactly
news to most of us the worst thing about
tattoos now is that they're cliched
since everyone has them and I say that
as somebody who has two as we're told
however Most states forbid children
those under the age of 18 from getting
these permanent markings on their bodies
yet 12 States or so around a dozen
states do allow tattoos on children with
no minimum age requirement at all as
long as they have parental consent back
to the article it says it is a situation
that Dr Cora Bruner a pediatrician and
professor at the University of
Washington Medical Center Seattle
Children's Hospital and author of
guidance on tattoos for pediatricians
issued by the American Academy
pediatrician pediatric medicine finds
troubling quote it is a permanent Mark
or a symbol you're putting on your body
I don't think kids under 18 have that
kind of agency to make a decision Dr
Bruner said we need to look at these
laws again
now personally I couldn't agree more
children do not have agency to make
permanent life-altering decisions it's
good to hear that the American Academy
of Pediatrics has reached this Common
Sense conclusion like most people the
American Academy of Pediatrics can
clearly see when it comes to tattoos
that children are impulsive suggestible
unable to Think Through the consequences
in fact the Times article Ends by
telling us that everyone involved in the
tattooing of the ten-year-old now
regrets it it says Miss Thomas the
parents in Highland New York uh near
Poughkeepsie described her case as a
misunderstanding she said she favored
age limits and that she had mistakenly
believed her son was asking for
permission to get a temporary tattoo no
little child should get tattooed she'd
said
um she has been charged with endangering
the welfare of a child a few days after
he was arraigned and Lloyd in Lloyd
justice court on charges of dealing
unlawfully with a child a misdemeanor
that can entail up to a year in prison
Mr Smith the tattoo artist said that he
is racked with deep regret over
tattooing the ten-year-old quote it's
the worst mistake I've made in my life
he said at the time I thought that if
you got your parents permission you
could get a tattoo as for Miss Thomas's
son today he feels differently about Mr
Smith's agreeing to give him a tattoo
quote he should have said no the boy
said
no you may be skeptical about the
mother's excuse here it's hard to see
how a misunderstanding could result in a
10 year old getting tattooed but the
point is that most people including the
American Academy Pediatrics
recognize that there is no good reason
to make these types of body
modifications to a child
yet it's hard not to notice
that their views on a child's ability to
consent and the propriety of making
permanent physical alterations to a
minor who lacks agency
seem to be rather inconsistent
after all the AAP also fully endorses
medical and surgical gender transitions
for children
the very group that when it comes to
tattoos they readily admit lack the
capacity to consent
this is not cognitive dissonance on the
part of the medical establishment for
them it's fully intentional
they know exactly what they're doing
they want you to have the cognitive
dissonance
they're trying to create or at least
exacerbate
a mental disconnect in your head
whereby you adopt an entirely different
set of values and priorities and
fundamental beliefs depending on the
topic
when it comes to tattoos you're meant to
see children as children incapable of
making these kinds of long-term choices
when it comes to gender transition
suddenly even a five-year-old possesses
agency the capacity for long-term
thinking
a deep and mature internal sense of what
is best for their own well-being
this is how the gender ideology game has
always worked as proponents want you to
see gender as its own world its own
Universe where entirely different
scientific and moral laws obtain the
whole thing comes crashing down once you
simply apply the same scrutiny to gender
ideology that you apply to everything
else
and that's why it's interesting that the
New York Times printed another story on
the same day which for the five people
who still read the print edition
appeared on the same page
and this one is titled they paused
puberty but is there a cost puberty
blockers can ease transgender use
anguish and buy time to weigh options
but concerns are growing about long-term
physical effects and other consequences
now the article is somewhat tentative in
its criticisms of puberty blockers but
it does say this quote
as the number of adolescents who
identify as transgender grows drugs
known as puberty blockers have become
the first line of intervention for the
youngest one seeking medical treatment
their use is typically framed as a safe
and reversible way to buy time to weigh
a medical transition and avoid the
anguish of growing into a body that
feels wrong transgender adolescents
suffer from disproportionately high
rates of depression other mental health
issues studies show that the drugs have
eased some patients gender dysphoria
distress over the mismatch of their
birth sex and gender identity but as an
increasing number of adolescents
identifies transgender in the United
States an estimated 300 000 aged 13 to
17 and an Untold number who are younger
concerns are growing among some medical
professionals about the consequences of
the drugs according to a New York Times
examination the questions are fueling
government reviews in Europe prompting a
push for more research and leading some
prominent Specialists to reconsider at
what age to prescribe them and for how
long a small number of doctors won't
recommend them at all there is emerging
evidence of potential harm from using
privy blockers according to reviews of
scientific papers and interviews with
more than 50 doctors and academic
experts around the world
we're then given a brief and incomplete
list of some of the complications from
these drugs but these are important
complications to list anyway it says the
drugs suppress estrogen and testosterone
hormones that help develop the
reproductive system but also affect the
bones the brain and other parts of the
body
during puberty bone mass typically
surges determining a lifetime of bone
health when adolescents are using
blockers bone density growth flat lines
on average according to an analysis
commission by the times of the
observational studies examining the
effects many doctors treating trans
patients believe they will recover that
loss when they go off the blockers but
two studies from the from the analysis
attract trans patients bone strength
while using blockers and through the
first years of sex hormone treatment
found that many do not fully rebound and
lag behind their peers that could lead
to heightened risks of debilitating
fractures earlier than will be expected
from normal aging in their 50s instead
of 60s and more immediate harm for
patients who start treatment with
already weak bones experts say
quote there's going to be a price said
Dr Sandeep kosla who uh leads a bone
research lab at the Mayo Clinic and the
price is probably going to be some
deficit in skeletal Mass
now the article does provide equal space
or better in fact better than equal
space to the other side quote unquote
and this mostly consists of lengthy
anecdotes and quotes from various
medical professionals making wild
assumptions about the totally
unsubstantiated alleged benefits of the
drugs
that doesn't matter
the point is that the New York Times is
acknowledging the criticisms of these
practices and even providing an accurate
though incomplete accounting of them
they are um in other words
legitimizing the debate
acknowledging that there is a valid
reason to doubt the mainstream consensus
now to be clear about this
I'm not giving them credit okay I'm not
I'm not applauding the New York Times
I'm not going to applaud them or
nominate them for a Pulitzer they're a
decade late to the party
and they had to be dragged Kicking and
Screaming to this point
we dragged them here because we are
shifting the Overton window
we are forcing the most mainstream media
institutions to take these arguments
seriously to give them an airing for
once
I mean none of us who've been in the
trenches on this issue will ever get
credit for the New York Times of course
they're not going to quote us they're
not going to say as so-and-so has always
said they're not going to do it but that
doesn't matter
we've done this and you could forget
about the election for a moment okay
um we are still winning Republican
politicians in many states may not be
but on this issue and other cultural
issues we are seeing progress this is
progress
and it's significant because the left
and this is on all issues but especially
this one of gender ideology
the left relies on manufactured
consensus
okay they can't defend their position
they can't do that
so instead they pretend that no other
position but theirs even exists
they present this united front which is
totally a facade
and they don't allow any opinion but
their own to be heard oxygen deprivation
is their greatest weapon they try to
suffocate the other side they declare
everyone agrees
even though everyone doesn't agree
for the people who don't agree don't get
a hearing they don't get a platform
and they keep declaring it that everyone
agrees until eventually in in so many
cases history shows everyone really does
agree
you know they can kind of manifest it if
they say there's a consensus and they
say it long enough and loud enough
then eventually a consensus sort of
forms they've manufactured one
now if they allow the other side to be
heard
then the public will know that there is
another side
and even that the other side is
reasonable and making evidence-based
logical arguments
the manufactured consensus crumbles
and their agenda goes down with it
I I predict that we will see and we are
now beginning to see this very thing
happening with gender ideology
we have punctured the manufactured
consensus bubble
and now we're going to see it all come
apart
now let's get to our five headlines
you know you could search for hours for
Reliable trustworthy information and
still not find what you're looking for
but what if you could find all the
information you need all in one place
completely free now you can with the
prageru mobile app prageru offers
accurate content fact-based content
about politics culture economics history
and America you can access it all and
Prager you uh the Prager mobile app
they've been reliably putting out
fact-based family-friendly pro-american
content for a long time and now with the
prageru mobile app you can get all the
great content you want from prageru like
their five minute videos their short
documentaries their popular podcasts all
of that 100 free download the prageru
mobile app right now on Google Play or
the Apple App Store and watch prageru
videos completely ad-free plus you'll
get exclusive access to never before
seen footage from private prageru events
with great thinkers like Dennis Prager
uh Jordan Peterson Christopher rufo and
many more it's fast easy and free with
the prageru mobile app you'll get all
the information you need to defend your
value share the truth and easily become
the smartest person in the roots who
download the prageru app today
all right so uh CNN correspondent Manu
Raju
reports a bipartisan group of senators
say they have a deal on a bill to codify
same-sex marriage and backers expect to
have 60 votes needed to break a
filibuster they release details of their
bill which the Senate punted until after
the elections
and by the way the the daily or rather
the blaze has also an article about this
naming some of these Senators says a
bipartisan group of senators is pushing
an amendment to the respect for Marriage
Act which includes a language
that is supposed to protect religious
liberty those lawmakers who include GOP
Senators Rob Portman of Ohio Susan
Collins of Maine Tom Tillis of North
Carolina and Democrat Senators Tammy
Baldwin and Kristen Cinema of Arizona
issued a statement promoting their
version of the measure
they say the respect for Marriage Act is
a needed step to provide millions of
loving couples in the same sex and
interracial marriages the certainty that
they will continue to enjoy the
Freedom's rights and responsibilities
afforded to all other marriages through
bipartisan collaboration we've created
common sense a language to confirm that
this legislation fully respects and
protects Americans religious Liberties
and diverse beliefs while leaving intact
the core mission of the legislation to
protect marriage equality we look
forward to this legislation coming to
the floor and are confident that this
amendment has helped earn the broad
bipartisan support needed to pass our
Common Sense legislation into law
well you know when they're calling it
common sense
I can't remember the last time they
called something Common Sense
legislation or a common sense Bill and
it actually contained any common sense
at all and that certainly isn't the case
here
so they're calling it the respect for
Marriage Act
ironically you know the orwellian
twisting twisting of language there the
respect for Marriage Act but what it
really is doing is codifying
um the destruction of marriage into
federal law
you know it's uh it's codifying on a
federal level the redefinition of
marriage
and they also include of course well
this is about same-sex couples and
interracial couples
conflating those two
when nobody is talking about interracial
couples no one has an issue with that
okay those of us who believe in and I
always put quotes around this
traditional marriage because that's a
qualifier that you know makes it sound
like there are many different forms of
valid marriage when really there isn't
but
um you know using that that language for
just a moment those of us who are
advocates for quote-unquote traditional
marriage uh no one in that group is is
criticizing interracial couples because
that does not challenge the fundamental
definition of marriage
our whole point is that marriage is
definitionally
uh in principle a procreative union
between man and woman it lies at the
foundation of of the family it's the
source from which the family Springs and
therefore is the foundation of
civilization
so clearly no matter what your races are
but no matter the racial configuration
of the coupling that that does not
challenge the definition of marriage
because these are still in principle
procreative unions whereas the union
between two men and two women is not
never can be and that's the point
now
the language here I'm not going to read
the entire thing but this is the
language that was added to the bill this
is what's getting a 60 vote you know
this is what's getting supposedly going
to get 60 votes in the Senate
um
and there's a whole bunch of stuff about
religious liberty
it says it protects all religious
liberty and conscious protections
available under the Constitution or
federal law including but not limited to
the religious freedom restoration act
and prevents this bill from being used
to diminish or repeal any such
protection it confirms that non-profit
religious organizations will not be
required to provide any service
facilities or Goods for the
solemnization or celebration of marriage
guarantees that this bill may not be
used to deny or alter any benefit right
or status of of an otherwise eligible
person or entity a lot of language like
that but then it all boils down to
the fact that again they are still
codifying at a federal level the radical
redefinition of marriage so they're
putting these supposed guard rails in
place to protect religious liberty
um and if you trust that okay if you
believe that any of this is actually
going to protect religious Liberties and
there's just there's nothing we can talk
about there's nothing I can say to you
if you're that naive then there's no
conversation that we can have
obviously if you do this
it is to begin with it's not just this
but it is also to begin with
um a threat to an attack on religious
liberty
that's where it ultimately leads
because if you're codifying on a federal
level
that two men have a right to get married
it's a human right a civil right
then that would mean by by extension
that uh you know that a church that
refuses to marry a gay couple is
depriving them of their basic human
civil rights
they may not be putting that language in
the bill exactly because they want it to
pass
but that's what it means and that's how
it will be used no matter what the bill
says
and I'll tell you this that you know
any Republican
who would sign on to a bill like this I
don't care if they have this
week you know they've created this
Trojan Horse now where they're
pretending that they're protecting
religious liberty doesn't matter any
Republican who would sign on to that
should be exiled from the party it won't
happen because this is the direction the
whole party is going
but that's what should happen
you know you are these These are
Republicans who
are signing on to something that only 10
years ago would have would have been too
radically far left for even the farthest
left people in the Democrat Party
ten years ago there was basically no one
in the Democratic party pushing for uh
pushing for this or very few anyway
certainly you go back
15 years ago and that was the case
[Music]
so a decade and a decade a decade you
know decade or a decade and a half you
go back it would be too far left for the
Democrats and now you've got
supposedly conservative Republicans
signing on to it
you cannot jump on board with the
redefinition of marriage and then think
that you're going to hold the line on
any other issue
this is the the the fundamental
Institution
this is the fundamental civilization you
know this is civilizations fundamental
Institution
marriage and the family
so you give up on that and so we don't
need to protect that anymore and then
what where are you drawing the line
after that you're going to erase that
line and redraw it where exactly
this is the uh
Republican party for you
and it's no surprise then that they
lost in the midterms or at least vastly
underperformed
because as I've been saying for the last
week they have no message
they're not really giving anyone a
reason to vote for them
and voters are saying hey if we want if
we want left-wing policies then we have
the Democrat Party for that what do we
need you for I mean you made yourself
irrelevant
so you're going to support
you know you're supporting leftist
policies
what what now count as moderately
left-wing policies and then you've got
extreme left-wing policies even though
even though again this would have been
extreme extreme left-wing policy 10 15
years ago
but voters who who want that they've
already got the Democrats for that
what do they need you for
you're not providing an alternative
okay provide an actual real alternative
to what the Democrats are offering
but will the voters go for that are we
at a point in our culture where the
voters just aren't going to be
interested in the alternative at all I
don't know exactly so we can't know
because we haven't done it yet
we don't have a political party there
are in effect just two political parties
in this country and we don't and it's
it's really a unit party there's there
is no real alternative
uh speaking of the manufactured
consensus fracturing Colin Wright who is
a a scientist and evolutionary biologist
also tweeted yesterday
biological sex is real immutable and
binary which of course is exactly
correct
um and then Sean Carroll
who's a prominent physicist and has been
you know he's he's been all over a TV
you've probably seen him in interviews
and
he's in the past has done a lot of uh
debates you know defending the The
Atheist world view he responded to it
and said actual science would like a
word
and he includes this chart with um lots
of words on it and the chart is titled
Beyond xx and x y
and there there's a lot going on the
chart there are a lot of words a lot of
colors
and this now he doesn't explain Sean
Carroll is obviously this is a prominent
scientist who has bought into gender
ideology
um he doesn't defend it or even explain
what he thinks this chart proves
he apparently thinks it proves that sex
is not binary that there are more than
two biological Sexes this is what a
mainstream incredibly prominent
highly educated
scientist is saying that there are more
than two biological sexes he doesn't go
beyond and explain any more of that
because he actually shut down comments
on his Twitter page after he posted this
this is because this is this is this is
how healthy scientific debate works
right you make a you make a statement
you don't defend it and then you stop
anyone from disagreeing with you that's
the scientific process now
but in fact there was pushback from
other scientists including Jerry Coyne
uh who's a biologist and as far as I
know not a conservative by any stretch
of the imagination
he responded he says actual science done
by biologists shows two Sexes one with
small mobile gametes and the other with
large immobile ones there is no third
sex disorders of sex development are not
new Sexes and biological sex is binary
let's not conflate sex gender and
developmental anomalies
well that's exactly the point because
you go back to this chart provided by
the physicist Sean Carroll which
apparently he got from a Scientific
American article and you look at it and
this is this is this is their attempt to
prove that sex is not binary that it's
on a spectrum and you look at what the
chart actually shows and uh again you're
not supposed to look at the chart you're
supposed to just see that there's a
chart there and and uh and you see the
title
this chart proves that sex is a spectrum
and then you're supposed to see just
like a bunch of words and arrows
pointing to stuff and be impressed with
that and then say well I guess sex isn't
a binary
but then when you actually look at it
the whole thing starts to falls apart
immediately because what you find is
you've got a one end of spec the
so-called Spectrum typical biological
female and then on the other end of the
spectrum you have typical biological
male and then you've got a bunch of
genetic abnormalities and conditions
that are randomly placed on this
spectrum
so for example
farther down like on the left side of
spectrum but far but but farther to the
right
on the female side of the spectrum
they have enlarged clitoris fused labia
short vagina normal ovaries uterix
cervix
okay so that's that's the description of
a uh of a of a a genetic condition
which on this chart puts you closer to
the male end of the spectrum
but then you look at that you say well
that's but that's not male at all that's
just a that's a female hasn't a large
clitoris and a fused labia
so this is a female with some
abnormalities physically but that's
still a just a female that's what that
is
if you have an enlarged clitoris as a
female then you're closer to male
what
this is what they this is what they do
I've told you this before but this is
this is how they've expanded the term
intersex
you know they've got what they what they
call the the the ideal you know they've
decided they being the people that come
up with this
um they've decided what what are sort of
the typical or ideal male or female and
if you're outside of what they consider
to be the ideal or the typical then your
intersex you're on a spectrum somewhere
so if you have an enlarged clitoris as a
female then you're closer to male on the
Spectrum
they also say that if you have an
abnormally small penis then you're
closer to female on the Spectrum
even though in the first case you're
still completely biologically female
and in the latter case you're completely
biologically male
now despite what Sean Carroll appears to
be claiming
variations within the sexes
do not count as a third sex these are
just variations within sex nobody ever
claimed that every male is is 100
physically identical to every other male
we're not all identical twins
okay no one ever claimed that there are
physical variations between within the
categories of male and female every male
is a little bit physically different
from every other male but they're still
all males just like every human is
physically different from any of every
other human but we're still all the same
species
foreign
this is what counts as or what they want
to say counts as science but you see
that it's it's the claims they're making
can't survive a debate if there is a
debate
which is wise for so long they've had
success in just making sure there is no
debate but they're that's not working
anymore
so Sean Carroll can can make this claim
and put the chart up but then he has to
shut down the comments because he's
being disputed by a whole bunch of
people including other scientists who
are saying this is
Sean and you know it
all right speaking of BS this is from
The Daily Mail says climate activists in
Austria today poured a black oily liquid
over Austrian painter Gustav klimps
Masterpiece death and life at Vienna's
Leopold Museum
so we're still doing this and there are
still people that are able to walk into
art museums holding buckets of paint and
nobody stops them
it says two members of the group last
generation through the die over the 1950
painting before one proceeded to glue
himself to the glass protecting the
Masterpiece a security guard at the
Museum managed to restrain one of the
activists before police arrived at the
site Museum staff are now concerned that
klims painting could have been damaged
in the protests a spokesperson for the
museum says restorers are working to
determine whether the painting protected
by glass has been damaged the last
generation group defended the protest
saying in a tweet that they were
protesting oil and gas drilling which
they called a death sentence to society
numerous masterpieces across Europe have
been attacked in recent weeks in
protests at the lack of action against
climate change
um and we have a video of it let's watch
the video
he walks in holding the pain no one
stops him
and he's still posing there
while someone else films like everyone
knows what's about to happen
another 95 year old security guard comes
in League
foreign
yeah it's it's it must be in I've never
been to an art museum where this has
happened I mean I've I don't think I've
been to like one art museum in my whole
life period but
um
it seems like it'd be pretty obvious if
they're if they're setting up to do
something like this it's pretty obvious
that they're about to do it
like if you see someone walking through
the museum with a big bowl of tomato
soup or holding you know a a container
of black paint
and they're wearing shirts
you know with climate slogans on them
and then someone's setting up to film
like you know it's going to happen how
about stop them ahead of time
I say again that this could all be
stopped immediately all of this kind of
stuff could be stopped immediately
overnight by giving just one of these
losers a 25-year prison sentence
okay
or and and as I've suggested when they
glue themselves to stuff there are two
approaches you could take there one is
to leave them glued to it just leave
them you know
um the other is to
remove them from whatever they've glued
themselves to
by removing the body part so you glue
your hand to something a painting then
we're going to cut your hand off
I mean if you don't want to have your
hand cut off don't glue it to a painting
don't glue it to something that's not
your property
or if you want to be nicer public
flogging 40 lashes
and I'm dead serious about it I mean if
I was in charge and you destroyed or
attempted to destroy a Priceless work of
art I would have you dragged out into
the street and beaten with a bull whip
until all the Flesh on your back has
been peeled off
that's what I would do okay and I would
make sure that there's a big crowd and
everyone sees me do it
um that and that's what a serious
country would do because that's Justice
it's severe it's immediate
public punishment
totally fully completely deserved
because how dare you I mean this is
we're talking about works of art made a
hundred years ago or more that uh that
that people have been coming to the to
the museum to enjoy for decades or
centuries
it is literally Priceless you cannot put
a price on it
and you think you could come along and
just try to destroy it because you're
having a temper tantrum
no it's a totally unacceptable Behavior
and until there's a response that
communicates that conveys how
unacceptable it is it will continue
this is what happens when action is
divorced from consequence
and these climate brats have have lived
a life where where that's the life they
live the action has been divorced from
from uh consequence or maybe the other
way around consequence divorced from
action
they can do what they want and they're
and the the natural consequences that
should follow don't
foreign
and you know what that not only
emboldens them to continue with this
but it also it also just contributes
even more to the nihilism
that encourages them to act this way in
the first place
because these people are not concerned
about saving the planet they're not
concerned about human life
if you were concerned about human life
you wouldn't be trying to destroy some
of the things that make life worth
living
art Beauty I mean these are the things
that make life worth living
and so if you loved human life that'd be
the last thing you'd be trying to
destroy
but they don't care about human life
they don't care about the planet
they're nihilists
they don't care about anything nothing
has meaning to them
this is one of the ultimate statements
of nihilism is to destroy you know a a
painting
a Priceless uh painting
historic artifact
now it's the same thing when they're
tearing down uh statues and all the rest
of it it is a statement of nihilism well
you only you're only encouraging more of
that
when people do not experience
consequences
for their evil and wicked Behavior
I mean these are already people who
think that nothing matters it does you
know nothing matters uh uh nothing has
any significance
and when they're able to just walk into
a art gallery and deface a painting like
that
with no consequence then that confirms
what they already suspected that nothing
matters nothing has any significance
just do what you want
foreign
you start
passing down severe punishments
um you not only are going to scare these
cowards none of them would risk it if
they thought there'd be a serious
consequence not a single one would risk
it not one
so you're not only scaring them straight
as it were
but you're also telling them that you
know what some things do matter like
think things some things do matter art
this this matters it matters to us
it is significant
and we're going to show you how much it
matters to us
all right
what else do we have here um interesting
claim made on The View yesterday about
uh I don't know this is a claim about a
a policy that apparently Republicans
have been supporting
this is news to me but I don't know
listen
but I will say this just like the Latina
saved the Senate young voters saved this
country and we need to really understand
that we are supposed to leave this world
in a better place than we found it when
you look at the youth voter turnout in
the 2022 midterms they delivered key
wins for the Democrats younger voters
aged 18 to 29 which by the way now the
Republicans want to raise the voting to
age 28. younger voters were the only
voter Group by age to overwhelmingly
support Democrats in the midterms 63
percent of Voters voted for Democrat
Democratic house candidates I think my
friend you know Cornell belker and you
know Cornell as well he says there are
really two electorates one older and one
younger fighting to take this country in
very different directions the Republican
party has to get with it they are dying
out and they are being here
up on time here
so what was that again rate she says by
the way you know Republicans I want to
raise the voting age to 28. what what
Republican has said that tell me what
Republicans said that because I would I
I would be supporting them I'd be
campaigning for them uh no no Republican
is saying that raise the voting age to
20. I haven't heard that from anyone now
you know you're also mistake like I'm
not pushing for raising the voting age
of 28 either I want to raise it to like
35.
um but I am far in a way in the minority
on that and I'm also not an elected
Republican
politicians and I have not heard any
suggest that we do that
um
and as we talked about yesterday
as much as I think that we should we
should raise the voting age
we should have all kinds of parameters
put in place there should be all kinds
of restrictions on voting that go Way
Beyond voter ID same-day voting I mean
that should just be the beginning of it
there should be so much more but but
none of that is going to happen
it should but it's not going to happen
and so we have to get to a point myself
certainly included in
dealing with
what actually is happening
yeah our our entire system of voting is
a joke and it only becomes more of a
joke every single day
but
if we want to have any chance of
changing any of that we have to deal
with that confront that
and as I said yesterday you know figure
out how to navigate the system and
exploit the systems that are in place
Republicans in some states have figured
out how to do that you know how do you
mobilize the the mass mail-in voting
early voting none of that should exist
it shouldn't exist but it does
and so are we going to allow Democrats
to be the only ones who utilize that
or are Republicans going to start
utilizing it too systems shouldn't be
there but it is
and so take advantage of it to the
extent that you can
because the only other app what's the
other option I don't see any other
option
the other option is to on principles say
no I'm not we're not going to do that
and then you just never win another
election ever again
and all of the you know policies that
you oppose all of that only gets worse
as a consequence
um
all right I wanted to mention this too
before we get to the
comment section because this relates to
something we talked about yesterday
and we talked about anxiety uh
depression the these uh supposed mental
illnesses that are are especially
affecting the younger generation and we
just heard from The View
that you know we should be we should be
following the lead of the Gen Z the
younger generation they they know what's
up I mean we should be fought we should
be taking their lead we should be
putting them in positions of leadership
and following them
uh meanwhile as we saw yesterday
you know studies show that
half of the of of of that generation
just about half has been diagnosed
mentally ill
and yet we should be following them and
taking their lead
well on that topic CNN has this
a mindfulness meditation course may be
as effective at reducing anxiety as a
common medication according to a new
study the research published on November
9th in Jama Psychiatry involved a group
of 276 adults with untreated anxiety
disorders half of the patients were
randomly selected to take 10 to 20
milligrams of a generic form of Lexapro
a common medication used to treat
anxiety and depression the other half
were assigned to an eight-week course in
mindfulness-based stress reduction the
results were stunning both groups
experienced about a 20 reduction in
their anxiety symptoms over the eight
week period Elizabeth Hodge is the lead
researcher told CNN that she hopes the
research can open up more treatment
options for patients with anxiety she
said Lexapro is a great drug I prescribe
it a lot but it's not for everyone
now listen I'm I'm not going to pretend
to be a proponent of mindfulness
meditation
mainly because I don't even know what
that is exactly I I've heard of it but
I'm not one for meditation personally
but at the same time
this is an important result
to uh to think about
because it shows that you know
whether you're whether it's meditation
or you know just going outside for a
walk getting some fresh air exercising
fixing your diet you know all of those
sorts of things
um
and also practicing and maybe this is
part of what meditation is supposed to
do I don't know but it's you know
learning how to take control of your
emotions or at least not be a slave to
them and that is a that is a skill and
no one is ever going to be 100 perfect
at it but you can develop your skill
and not being a slave to your emotions
sometimes it's a matter of like fake it
until you make it
okay you're feeling down you're feeling
anxious act like you aren't feeling that
way
and very often you'll discover
as you you're acting the part you're
pretending and then a moment's gonna
come where you look back and you realize
oh I'm actually not I'm I feel better
now
um
and these sorts of strategies
they do work they can work
we don't need to rely on drugs
because as it turned you know as much as
we hear that something like anxiety and
depression these are physical diseases
it's no different than cancer or no
different than diabetes that's what they
tell us anyway
and yet no one is recommending
meditation for cancer
now as a way to kind of psychologically
deal with a cancer diagnosis or
something that might be one thing but
but as far as treating the cancer itself
obviously you're not going to do that
with meditation and I wouldn't say that
you're going to do that by taking walks
and and you know all of that sort of
thing
but with things like anxiety and
depression you can actually treat the
quote illness itself through those sorts
of
practices
because actually it's not an illness in
the same way that a physical illness is
an illness it's not the same sort of
thing as cancer or diabetes or arthritis
it's something in your mind
and it is also an inexorable part of the
human condition
which doesn't mean it's not serious
which doesn't mean that we shouldn't uh
take people seriously when they say
they're struggling with it
just means that we should be looking at
a different sort of approach
all right let's get to the comment
section do you know that
they're the sweet baby game
by the way you know I hate to have to
keep coming to you guys for emotional
support on this issue but uh
here's what my wife tweeted this morning
she said
I've been informed that Matt is trying
to bring the eight foot walrus home this
week he claims our house is big enough
for this monstrosity I don't have the
room or desire to incorporate it into my
beautiful rooms
I'll leave my Christmas tree up all year
if he does this watch me
okay first of all she already leaves the
Christmas tree up all year basically
second this is what I'm I'm dealing with
now so I've managed to secure my rights
to the walrus
but I haven't been able to bring it home
because one battle just led to a tougher
battle and this time the opponent is my
wife who refuses to allow the walrus
into our house and we've had so many
discussions about this and it's all the
more
uh disappointing to me because we have
we have a Biblical household and a
Biblical marriage and Ephesians 5
clearly says a wife must submit to her
husband
um including in all matters walrus
related and that last part isn't
actually in the text but I think you can
infer it
and she keeps arguing though that we
don't have room for the walrus you know
the walrus is too big it would be
embarrassing she actually said that she
said it would be embarrassing I'd be
embarrassed to have
the walrus in the house and it's like oh
you're embarrassed by Johnny the walrus
Johnny walrus is paying the mortgage on
this house okay this walrus has a right
to be in this house
um
and meanwhile she fills our home
with Furniture throw pillows random
pieces of like random decorations
she'll go by she'll go buy like a a
decorative I don't know wheelbarrow or
something and put it in the dining room
yet if I want to bring one walrus home
suddenly it's a problem
last time we moved okay
I don't even realize all the stuff she's
bought until we move and I have to move
the stuff and so last time we moved I
remember I I made like five separate
trips
to Lug a whole bunch of old-fashioned
glass milk jugs we just with dozens of
them and I and I'm and I said to her why
do we have these what is this and she
said oh it's decor
the core for what a dairy farm what why
do this is decor
so here's all I'm going to say this is
this is it this is really all I'm going
to say
if and I'm just saying if
if the crew here at the daily wire
decided that you know we don't want the
walrus taking up a room in the studio
anymore
and so unbeknownst to me and unbeknownst
to my wife
if they were to just of their own
volition
load the thing into a truck or van and
drive it to my house and show up with it
and knock on the door and say hey we
have your walrus do you want us to bring
it in or just leave it on in in you know
in the driveway
if they were to do that then at that
point I think my wife would have no
choice but to accept the walrus
especially because what the other thing
that would happen is that my kids who
are all like little puppy dogs and
anytime the doorbell rings they just run
to the door they would show up and they
would see the walrus and they would know
what their mother is trying to deprive
them of
and and and and they would they would
have an emotional breakdown if she said
we can't take the lower so
I'm not advocating that okay I'm not
saying that I'm that's not my point I'm
just saying that if all those things
were to happen
then I would have the wall or something
else
that's it that's it okay
um
the drummer's Workshop says the problem
with a lot of gen Z is that they get
rewarded for being mediocre
then they can't understand with all the
quick Fame they've achieved why they
still feel unfulfilled
and rational bacon which remains one of
my favorite YouTube usernames uh agrees
with this as kids today are taught that
any suffering is Unthinkable cruelty
being older we grew up expecting tragedy
it made us appreciate Good Times bubble
wrapping children robbed them of true
happiness
yeah and that's uh and that's that's the
point is that you know
when when you've got all these gen ZL
these younger people running around as
we said yesterday there was a something
like 20 20 of the 50 that has been
diagnosed with mental illness 20 of that
50 have actually been diagnosed with
PTSD
and again not because they're all a
bunch of combat veterans I mean maybe
some of them are but uh but the vast
majority we can assume not
and yet they have PTSD
and that's that's real to us in a
certain way
now they haven't really experienced
anything that should actually cause
trauma
but they do really feel traumatized
because they've never learned how to
deal with just the normal
disappointments that come with life
they've never been given that skill
they've never been taught how to hone
that skill
and so now anytime they they encounter
any obstacle at all they they just they
they break down they can't handle it
they don't know how to handle it
and then we write them off as well
they're mentally ill just give them
drugs
the drugs might uh they might numb some
of some of this they you know they might
be a Band-Aid solution for some of this
but they aren't going to teach them the
skill
they're gonna they're gonna teach them
how to deal with life how to deal with
living a human existence
Aaron says Matt I hear you often
criticize the GOP focus on tax cuts I
think it's misguided the problem is that
they isn't that they promise tax cuts
but that they promise them and don't
follow through well my issue isn't with
the idea of tax cuts it's with making
tax cuts or issues like tax cuts the
central aspect of their agenda and their
campaigns tax cuts aren't going to save
the problem aren't going to save the
country tax cuts aren't going to
motivate voters to go to the polls the
same way that other issues do tax cuts
are just an easy thing to Pander with
and that's my issue with it but as far
as tax cuts go
I mean I'm all in favor of them I'm in
favor of any tax cut for anyone because
I like the idea of people keeping their
own money and I like the idea of the
government getting less money government
already gets trillions of dollars
trillions every single year in its
income that's its income
um and I think that's quite enough in
fact too much and so I'm in favor of
them getting less and US keeping more of
our money so I like that and I think the
whole idea of an income tax is
outrageous and tyrannical and we only
accept it because we've never known
anything else in our lifetimes
the founding fathers they staged a
rebellion because they didn't want to
pay a tax on T okay and I know that
there was a lot more to it than that I
realized but still they were upset about
attacks on T and here we are paying
taxes on I mean we pay taxes on T okay
you go get an Arizona Iced Tea at
Walgreens it's gonna there's gonna be
taxed but we also pay taxes on on
everything else we pay taxes on
everything everywhere all the time
including paying a tax for simply
earning a living we pay a tax for
existing and for dying
if you exist or if you if you're born if
you exist and then if you die you have
to pay tax and all that a hefty tax
and when it comes to the tax on existing
which is the income tax
the government extracts it from our
paychecks before we even get a cut of
our own paychecks I despise the whole
idea of it
actually this is one of my problems with
the Republican obsession with tax cuts
it's that it doesn't go nearly far
enough it doesn't solve anything
shaving off a percentage or two
only to have the Democrats raise it
again what does that solve was that what
does that achieve in the long run or in
the short run
be bold have some conviction go for the
whole thing
attack the system at its foundation its
roots talk about talk about abolishing
the IRS there are a few Republicans
talking about that Ted Cruz has talked
about that
that's a bold
uh Revolution that would be a revolution
in our country to get rid of the of the
IRS completely get rid of the income tax
completely
but that's what Republicans do they're
all they're always just dancing around
the edges at best
if you want to see one of the most
important things I've done in my life
especially my in my career certainly you
have to check out my documentary what is
a woman it has more than 5 000 audience
ratings on Rotten Tomatoes and even five
reviews from critics who are brave
enough to touch it just in the month
after we released what is the woman the
daily wire gained more members than at
any other time in our history just goes
to show that if you make something worth
watching unlike most Hollywood films
people will watch it in droves if you
haven't seen it yet go to
whatisawoman.com to watch it right now
that's whatisawoman.com today now let's
get to our daily cancellation
foreign
I have neglected to mention until this
moment that this week is transgender
awareness week which leads us up to
transgender Remembrance Day and it's
important that we have this week and
that day to become aware of and remember
trans people just as it's crucial that
we have LGBT pride month and LGBT
history month and LGBT Spirit day and
pronoun awareness day and International
Day against homophobia transphobium
biphobia and so on it's clear that there
is not a special
um that if there is not a special
holiday recognizing and calling
attention to LGBT people and especially
trans people and if we don't have this
holiday at least twice a month then we
will all forget that these people exist
and they will immediately
evaporate it'll be like that show the
leftovers which is a great show by the
way depicting an apocalyptic scenario
where a large portion of the Earth's
population suddenly vanishes Without a
Trace
and the creator of that show never said
this explicitly but it's clear that it
was supposed to be a parable about what
will happen if we don't have enough LGBT
awareness days
so we must always remain aware we must
make sure that everyone else is aware
that the LGBT Club stays at the center
of everything always no matter what
forever
and so to that end the men's World Cup
team is doing its part
providing further evidence that soccer
is gay uh the men's team has redesigned
their official Crest to get rid of the
American flag colors and instead
incorporate the rainbow flag from The
Daily Mail it says the United States is
uh the United States Men's National Team
have made a huge statement at the world
topic Guitar World Cup of Guitar by
redesigning their Crest to incorporate
the rainbow flag in a bid to show
solidarity with the lgbtq plus Community
the tournament which starts on Sunday
and sees the U.S play their opener
against Wales on Monday has been hugely
controversial in its build up given
qatar's human rights record and attitude
to human sexual homosexuality as
recently as this month a Qatar World Cup
Ambassador told a German TV broadcaster
that homosexuality was damaged to the
mind and it remains illegal to be gay in
the conservative Muslim country the usmt
appeared to have made an immediate stand
on their arrival in Doha though by
changing their usual red stripes on
their Crest to a rainbow around their
team base pictures from the AL garafa SC
stadium and our our Ryan
where the U.S has trained on Monday
showed a huge U.S Crest on the wall
alongside the slogan One Nation it has
understood the crest on the team's kits
on the field won't be changed but the
new colors will be shown off at their
practice facilities
so as you can see the Crest is actually
an example really of trans Erasure
rather than trans awareness as it only
includes the colors on the old LGBT flag
that's the bigoted hateful LGBT flag of
our ancestors the one that looks tacky
but lacks the boldness and courage to be
totally chaotic and vomitous and hideous
like you know a unicorn vomited all over
it as of course the current
trans-inclusive flag looks
yet fortunately the other colors are
represented elsewhere in their practice
facility after all it's not just about
the crest you know U.S soccer is doing
an entire LGBT Rebrand reading more from
The Daily Mail says Neil buth the USM
nt's Chief Communications officer told
dailymail.com our rainbow badge has an
important and consistent role in the
identity of U.S soccer as part of our
approach for any match or event we
include rainbow branding to support and
embrace the lgbtq community as well as
to promote a spirit of inclusiveness and
welcoming to all fans across the globe
as a result locations that we will
manage and operate at the FIFA World Cup
such as the team Hotel Media areas and
parties will feature both traditional
rainbow U.S soccer branding so it will
have the traditional flag and also the
rainbow flag
now you may point out that if U.S soccer
is actually concerned about qatar's
record on quote LGBT rights
they could make a much greater statement
by refusing to participate in the World
Cup in the first place
I mean by simply showing up and
participating they are financially
supporting the country that they claim
to be protesting against
which is a bit like protesting JK
Rowling by buying a Harry Potter book
and then burning it I mean you've
already bought the book or protesting
Elon Musk by buying a Tesla and then
running it into a telephone pole on
purpose you've already given your
financial support it's a little bit too
late whatever statement you make in the
process or afterwards is now irrelevant
but then of course this is the whole
point of virtue signaling that's why we
call it virtue signaling not virtue
doing
we don't call it virtue doing because
there is no virtue involved here in
first place and also because nothing is
being done
the corporate gay pride stuff is all
just sheep's Blood on the door signaling
that they are the chosen people so that
the angel of cancellation passes them
over
but as far as symbolism goes
I think it is appropriate that they
should replace the colors of the
American flag with the colors of the
LGBT flag I mean it's horrendous it's
traitorous it's treasonous
if I was in charge of the country they
wouldn't be they wouldn't be allowed
back into the country
but
it's also appropriate because the LGBT
Nation
LGBT a stand we may call it is after all
the country that Corporate America as
well as the United States government
seeks to represent it is the nation that
the left pledges allegiance to
it is the country that wishes to
colonize the world and export its ideas
and values to corners of the globe that
have no interest in them
now I've often said that the alphabet
Club is a religious cult
and it is that certainly
but maybe on second thought it's better
understood in this way as a country
it has its own flag
its own national holidays its own myths
and traditions its own sports teams
and it has its own government too which
is formerly known as the United States
government
now some people predict that we will
eventually in the future become two
countries you know there's gonna be some
kind of Civil War
the point is that we're already two
countries
there's one that salutes the pride flag
and despises the American flag and one
that salutes the American flag and has
no use for the pride flag
at this point it's only a matter of
making the split official I suppose
something that we will probably never do
but we should
and that is why U.S soccer is today
canceled though really a lot of
unnecessary words there because U.S
soccer is already canceled because it's
soccer
so canceled on two levels there and
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you